and now to the continued chaos in
Ukraine after an important Dam in
russian-held territory was destroyed
Drone footage shows serious flooding in
areas that already were under Fire and
there have been several deaths reported
ahead of Ukraine's long-anticipated
counter-offensive against Russia Deborah
patta reports from Ukraine
evacuating residents from her son is a
deadly business
votes move swiftly through
flood-stricken areas not only ferrying
people to dry land but to escape the
ongoing Russian bombardment
this elderly man was rescued by
volunteers from his submerged home only
to be filmed moments later with a head
wound caused by flying shrapnel a rescue
worker was asked what it was like
operating under these conditions
before indicating he needed to get going
because of incoming fire dear friends we
just Ukraine's
was helping emergency crews bring
residents to safety when more shelling
landed nearby to bring people over here
from all the river and the Russian
in the eastern part of the country
Ukrainian troops have stepped up
offensive operations around the
beleagued city of Bahamut which was only
recently taken by Russian troops the
keep says it's made steady gains along a
wide front line U.S officials have told
CBS news that there has also been an
increase in fighting in a key region
along the southern front but CBS
mornings Deborah patter harkiv